este es el aspecto que tenía antes el
puerto principal de tonga y así se ve
ahora barrios enteros de color verde
exuberante se cubrieron de ceniza tras
la erupción del volcán jung a tonga
jungla para el sábado pidiendo ayuda en
las redes sociales el propietario de un
resort de surf al oeste de la capital
dijo que todas las instalaciones frente
a la playa en la zona han sido
gravemente dañadas o completamente
eliminadas por un tsunami provocado por
la erupción submarina la ayuda
extranjera está en camino con aviones y
barcos de la marina enviados desde
australia y nueva zelanda pero el
aeropuerto sigue cerrado con su pista
inutilizada por los escombros el tsunami
corte el principal cable de
comunicaciones submarino de tonga por lo
que la población solo se puede comunicar
con teléfonos satelitales
las cenizas son bastante problemáticas
no sólo para el agua y el saneamiento
porque tonga recoge el agua de los
tejados de los hogares sino para el
acceso a la ayuda de australia nueva
zelanda y otros vuelos deben despejar la
pista de aterrizaje white
y el país del pacífico está formado por
176 islas 40 de ellas habitadas y
dispersas naciones unidas dice que se
detectó una señal de socorro en el grupo
de islas de hawai la pandemia podría
complicar aún más la llegada de ayuda un
funcionario de tonga aseguró que
cualquier asistencia personal del
extranjero debe cumplir una cuarentena y
es poco probable que se permita el
desembarco de personas del exterior por
temor a llevar al virus a la nación
libre de kobe 19 aunque se dice que
muchos residentes han escapado del
tsunami se ha encontrado el cuerpo de
una mujer británica que vivía en
nuku'alofa una de las primeras muertes
confirmadas del desastre